bonsoir à tous je ne sais pas si on
ce soir on va essayer de penser pour
commencer on va peut-être
rendre vous connaissez peut-être cette
image les grecs les anciens grecs pensé
que c'était le centre du monde c'est le
sanctuaire de delphes
alors vous savez peut-être la pitite et
sur son trépied et puis elle parlait au
nom d'apollon pour répondre aux
questions des grecs et vous savez que
d'un côté de ce temple d'apollon il y
avait écrit le fameux gnoti ses automnes
connais toi toi même lorsqu'on sait
moins c'est que de l'autre côté il y
avait écrit rien de trop rien de trop
les grecs avait le génie de la mesure il
haïssait l'excès et je crois que les
grecs auraient à y notre époque pourquoi
parce que nous entrons nous sommes de
plus en plus dans l'ère des extrêmes
dans l'ère de la polarisation
en fait la civilisation depuis toujours
elle a cherché à surmonter toutes les
difficultés tout ce qui pouvait limiter
notre capacité à être excessif regard
des expressions le jeu n'en vaut pas la
chandelle
parce que la chandelle pendant très
longtemps coûtait trop cher donc il
fallait bien mesurer si on avait
vraiment envie de veiller quand la nuit
était tombée on était dépendant du jour
et de la nuit on était dépendant des
saisons et puis on a inventé
évidemment les maisons le fait de se
chauffer le fait de s'habiller on a pu
aller habiter d'autres endroits du globe
où normalement nous ne pouvions pas
vivre
petit à petit nous avons réduit à néant
tous les garde-fous tout ce qui nous
empêchait de vivre dans nos excès
regardez par exemple nous n'étions pas
fait pour les excès de sucre 40% des
adultes américains sont aujourd'hui
classés comme obèses mais cet excès
n'était rien à travers à côté de ce qui
est en train d'arriver avec l'ère
numérique
car l'ère numérique et c'est ce que je
vais essayer de vous dire ce soir l'ère
numérique a abattu tous les garde-fous
toutes les limites
tout ce qu'ils allaient faire que nous
ne pouvions pas être excessif et nous
sommes entrés dans une ère d extrême
dans tous les niveaux économique social
et politique
la société que nous voulons à 3 à 3
dimensions
la transaction c'est à dire l'économie
la liaison la relation le fait d'être
ensemble et puis l'information et
l'information c'est le pouvoir
on va voir que ces trois piliers
aujourd'hui sont en train de se
polariser le premier c'est la
transaction aujourd'hui nous sommes de
plus en plus dans une économie qui
oppose seigneur et vassaux autrefois il
y avait des limites géographiques très
rapide au marché vous souvenez en 1790
quand on a fait les départements on
avait fait les chefs lieux pour que il
faille une journée à cheval au maximum
pour aller jusqu'au chef-lieu une
journée à cheval au xviie siècle et au
début du 18e pour aller de paris à lyon
il fallait dix jours pour aller de paris
à marseille i falé quinze jours si vous
vouliez aller en chine c'était un an
pour y aller c'était un an pour revenir
aujourd'hui il y à un train chinois qui
met quinze jours entre la chine et lyon
il y en aura cinq mille par an dans les
années 60 le plus grand porte-conteneurs
pouvait en avoir six mille 6000
équivalent six pieds comme on dit
aujourd'hui ils peuvent en avoir jusqu'à
onze mille la taille des marchés a
augmenté et a apporté avec elle la
taille des entreprises
mais ça n'est absolument rien là encore
à côté de ce que le numérique permet car
le numérique a fait disparaître la
frontière géographique le problème de la
géographie de l'espace vous pouvez grâce
à la scalabilité de votre offre
offrir à toute l'humanité en même temps
la même offre
et c'est ce qui produit des entreprises
si grande et cette économie bifaces
comme disent les économistes ou les
plateformes domine le monde
souvenons nous au viiie siècle charles
martel qui a remplacé les mérovingiens
par les carolingiens avec son fils pépin
le bref quelle était sa fonction il
était maire du palais le maire de pas
laissées qui en fait c'est l'intendant
c'est celui qui s'occupe de la
logistique
quand vous maîtrisez l'entrée du palais
quand vous maîtrisez l'intendance vous
avez le pouvoir
en réalité c'est ce qui s'est passé
autrefois et que par le bref c'est ce
qui est en train de se passer avec les
gaffes à
ses gaffes à dont la taille ne cesse de
grandir en 2018 les plus grandes
capitalisations boursières du monde
c'était alphabet que vous connaissez
évidemment sous le nom de google
c'était amazon s'était pas facebook un
peu plus petits c'est n 7 et n 7 est
évidemment apple
si vous prenez les 100 plus grandes
capitalisations boursières
ça fait vingt mille milliards c'est égal
au quart du pib mondial
ces entreprises ont une taille
absolument inouïe facebook à 2,3
milliard d'inscrits c'est 30 % de
l'humanité vivante aujourd'hui ça
n'aurait jamais été possible évidemment
autrefois et ses entreprises agissent un
petit peu comme des trous noirs qui
absorbent la lumière puisqu'ils
réalisent ils sont capables ils ont
l'argent pour acheter toutes les
innovations qui passe à portée
en dix ans les gaffes à on fait gaffe
âme avec microsoft ont fait 400 achat
majeur depuis 1996 google en a fait plus
de 2 100 achat majeur pour un montant de
37 milliards de dollars
les entreprises ne cessent de grandir et
elles ont l'exclusivité de la relation à
vous et elles ont l'exclusivité de la
relation entre le marché et de vous vers
le marché essaie ça évidemment qu'elle
parvienne à monétiser la deuxième chose
qui est en train de se polariser
complètement c'est la société c'est la
relation c'est vous savez wells qui
avait écrit cet extraordinaire livre la
machine à remonter le temps
dans laquelle dans lequel il explique en
lan 6000 il imagine que l'humanité s'est
divisée en deux il ya d'un côté les
morlocks qui vivent sous terre qui sont
les producteurs aient pu en haut il ya
la race un peu été ré tout diaphane des
elohim qui d'ailleurs sont bouffés la
nuit par les morlocks mais cela
pourrait-il d'histoire deux humanités
complètement différente c'est est ce
qu'on imaginait au 19e siècle
la conséquence d'une polarisation total
de façon un peu troublante c'est ce qui
a l'air de commencer a réémergé à
l'auteur qui s'appelle lipietz qui a
expliqué que nous passions de la société
en losange avec beaucoup de gens au
milieu quelques extrême à la société en
sablier avec beaucoup de gens extrêmes
et de moins en moins de gens à
l'intérieur et c'est vrai qu'on a cet
élément de dualité de dualité dans les
années 30
ils ont rapporté un dialogue fameux cas
peut-être pas eu lieu mais enfin bon il
est devenu légendaire entre fitzgerald
celui du goulet de gatsby et hemingway
fitzgerald dit tu sais les riches ne
sont pas comme nous hemingway on est
dans les années 30 10 oui c'est vrai ils
ont plus d'argent
la seule différence entre les riches et
les pauvres dans les années 30 c'était
l'argent aujourd'hui de plus en plus la
différence entre les riches et les
pauvres aller beaucoup plus fondamentale
elle est dans les modes de vie dans les
références le vocabulaire est tout la
façon de vivre
c'est ce que montrent par exemple murray
dans un livre qui s'appelle coming op
art où il explique que depuis les années
60 il ya une différence avec une
dichotomie za sion si je peux me
permettre ce mot dans la société
américaine alors que jusque-là à l'été
de façon assez exemplaire extrêmement
unie dans ses références comme nos
portes
c'est à dire vous avez une une
différence de plus en plus grande entre
les entre les deux on peut parler les
économistes parlent d'un effet mathieu
savait car on donnera à celui qui a
il sera dans l'abondance mais à celui
qui n'a pas on notera même ce qu'il ce
qu'il ce qu'il a on pourrait aussi
parler moi j'ai eu l'idée d'appeler ça
l'effet cyrano vous savez dans cyrano on
parle des moulins le moulin il peut vous
projeter dans les étoiles où vous
projeter à terre
aujourd'hui on voit que dans notre
société numérique c'est exactement ce
qui se passe puisque oui tout est one
click away le savoir est à une portée de
clic
sauf que vous allez probablement 30 % de
français qui n'arrivent pas à avoir
réellement accès au savoir parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas utiliser internet
déjà on avait 20 % d'illettrés
évidemment quand vous étiez les traits
dans la vie c'est compliqué de ne pas
être illettré numériquement donc vous
avez des gens qui ne feront pas ce clic
et la société numérique donne des ailes
extraordinaire à tous les gens qui sont
dans cette salle
tous les gens qui sont connectés à la
mondialisation on pourrait prendre aussi
l'image d'un train plus le train david
plus la différence entre ceux qui sont
restés sur le quai et ceux qui sont dans
le train s'agrandit rapidement cette
différence elle devient de plus en plus
préoccupante et on peut avoir peur
effectivement d'avoir demain d'un côté
des tic des techno leader hyper
connectés et de l'autre des techno
largué sans aucun espoir de pouvoir
apporter de la valeur à la société est
de trouver évidemment évidemment un
emploi cette dichotomie nation elle se
voit aussi dans quelque chose qui a déjà
existé dans l'histoire
autrefois les grandes villes de la
romaine du temps la pax romana étaient
ouvertes sur la campagne parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de problème de sécurité
et on voit une civilisation vaud va mal
à l'aune des murs qu'elle est obligée
d'édifier et évidemment les châteaux
forts a été là ça a été la réponse à
l'époque à cette insécurité extrême qui
était revenu or que voyons nous nous
sommes en train de rédiger des murs
évidemment entre le mexique et les états
unis
des murs physiques mais aussi des murs
économique parce que la grande
différence aujourd'hui de plus en plus à
l'est entre les territoires extrêmement
prospère hyper prospère et puis les
territoires complètement à l'abandon
entre la ville entre les hyper métropole
qui se développe
et puis et puis les autres l'afrique ici
30 ans va doubler de taille atteindra 2
milliards cinq cent mille habitations
millions par dont 2 milliards 500
millions d'habitants entre temps soit un
doublement de taille la ville de la
baule sont deux générations
elle est passée de 200 mille personnes à
20 millions et elle s'étend aujourd'hui
sur plus de mille kilomètres carrés
vous avez d'un côté une hyper croissance
des villes et d'un autre côté des
territoires de plus en plus à l'abandon
cette dichotomie on ne sait pas à
l'heure actuelle comment la règle et
évidemment elle a une conséquence
économique extrêmement fort depuis la
troisième le troisième pilier
c'est évidemment c'est l'information et
c'est le pouvoir alors à gauche vous
avez quoi vous avez évidemment l'hyper
totalitarisme chinois avec le système de
notation sociale
ce système a d'ores et déjà interdit de
transport 23 millions de chinois
à l'heure actuelle vous avez en chine
300 millions de caméras dans deux ans il
en aura 1 milliard caméras sont
directement recoupées avec vos données
déplacement avec vos données d'achat et
alex que vous racontez sur ichat
tout est ouvert tout est collecté par
l'état tout est contrôlé ça vous donne
une super notation sociale et donc un
contrôle parfait de l'autre côté qu'est
ce que vous avez les hypers démocratie
j'ai mis une photo d'un activiste vegan
qui se fait marquer au fer rouge pour
protester contre le fait de manger de la
viande
nous avons des sociétés démocratiques
qui arrive de moins en moins organisé un
débat qui sont plutôt des juxtapositions
de groupes qui deviennent de plus en
plus violents du fait de leur incapacité
à dialoguer pourquoi cause évidemment du
tsunami de données du data nami vous
êtes tous ces très jeunes dans cette
salle mais vous venu quand même de du
monde d'avant du monde où les structures
d'éducation ont été faites pour un monde
où la formation étaient rares et donc
l'information vous aviez à l'avait déjà
été sélectionnés alors qu'aujourd'hui
notre problème il exactement inverse
l'information elle est infini et notre
problème c'est d'arriver à sélectionner
la bonne
mais dans ce monde d'information infinie
l'information qui ressort n'est en fait
en général que l'information la plus
extrême celle qui va faire que on s'en
souviendra
celle qui va faire que elle va être
frappante
drôle et donc ce n'est pas l'information
la plus pertinente
autrefois on arrivait parfaitement à à
contrôler l'information en 1633 quand on
a voulu faire dire à galilée que la
terre était bien le centre du monde et
que c'était pas à quelle ne tournait pas
évidemment autour du soleil et ce qui
est totalement absurde
eh bien on a pu lui faire un procès et
on l'a fait
terre dans les années 70 il y avait une
chaîne de télé c'était facile de
contrôler l'information qu'ils avaient
quelques médias et le président la
république pouvait toujours décrocher
son téléphone pour arriver à éviter
certains sujets aujourd'hui 62% des
américains s'informent d'abord et avant
tout sur les réseaux sociaux et sur les
réseaux sociaux évidemment vous ne
pouvez pas contrôler ce qui s'échange
c'est à la fois extraordinaire d'un
point de vue démocratique et à la fois
on s'en rend compte aujourd'hui dans nos
vieilles démocraties terrible car le
dialogue démocratique n'a plus lieu
parce qu'il ya des effets cognitifs par
exemple comme ce terrible effet downing
kruger qui fait que moi on connaît un
sujet plus on est persuadé qu'on connaît
et que les vrais savants sont pleins de
doutes et que l'ignorant la plupart du
temps malheureusement est persuadé qu'il
s'est alors il ya des sites
extraordinaires qui sont des sites en
fait fait pour faire de l'argent comme
celui-là on sait ce qu'on veut qu'on
sache été formés fermé depuis
mais c'est un site qui bat pour
pourrait dire façon de fonctionner de
vous proposer des trucs hyper choquant
du type l'ail et 15 fois plus puissant
que les antibio les attentats contre
charlie sont organisés par le
gouvernement
la conséquence un sondage l'année
dernière avait montré vous savez que 32%
des français des français pensaient que
sida avait été inventé en laboratoire
puis inoculé à l'homme et que 9% des
français pensaient que la terre était
plate
on pensait qu internet elle est libérée
l'information et le savoir il a rendu le
savoir invisible nous sommes tous dans
une bulle qui malheureusement est
souvent une bulle des pensées les plus
extrêmes vous tapez vaccin sur amazon
regarder ce qui va vous donner il va
vous donner que des livres anti vaccins
à partir du moment où vous serez à le
voir par curiosité des livres anti
vaccins on vous proposera d'autres trucs
anti vaccins et ça y est vous êtes
enfermé dans la bulle du délire ça
malheureusement ça nous arrive tous ces
bulles cognitive évidemment depuis
l'élection de trump on les connaît
internet c'est évidemment aussi la
manipulation avérée de puissances
extérieures à travers la manipulation
d'informations et le relais voire la
production d'informations plus ou moins
fausse en tout cas vu sous certains
angles
la politique est la continuation de la
guerre par d'autres moyens
les médias traditionnels autrefois
étaient des sélectionneurs de
l'information aujourd'hui il court après
l'information des réseaux sociaux est la
seule façon pour eux de surnager et
d'être encore plus extrêmes c'est-à-dire
d'inviter des gens qui vont d'abord se
[ __ ] sur la gueule de préférence
d'inviter des gens qui vont incarner les
points de vue les plus extrêmes et donc
pas augmenter le phénomène de
polarisation il est d'ailleurs assez
rigolo de constater une étude qui a
montré que ceux qui utilisent plus de
sept réseaux sociaux ont trois fois plus
de chance
d'être en dépression que ceux qui en
utilisent moins de 3,3 et moins plus
vous utilisez les réseaux sociaux plus
vous êtes anxieux et déprimé et -
peut-être vous êtes forcément informés
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire parce
que je veux pas vous laisser sans
viatique d'abord retrouver sens de la
mesure
retrouver le sens de la mesure vous
savez c'est cette déesse qui s'appelait
nemesis qu'est qu'on était représentée
avec le coup de plier parce que le coût
de plier c'était justement la mesure le
fait qu'on était mesuré on n'était pas
dans l'infini retrouvons le sens de la
mesure
retrouvons le sens de la némésis c'est
paul valéry qui disait le monde ne vaut
que par les extrêmes mais il ne tient
que par les modérés nous avons tous
besoin de redevenir des modérés de ne
pas donner toutes nos données au babc le
mans à la même plateforme de ne pas
dépendre volontairement de la même
plateforme c'est possible on peut le
faire
facebook il ya quelques mois a été fermé
pendant quelques heures
télégramme a enregistré plus de 3
millions de nouveaux de nouvelles
inscriptions on peut très facilement
sans aller dans le système c'est one
click away mais encore faut-il le faire
cet effort d'aller onekey cauwet
retrouvons le sens de la mesure nous
pouvons résister mais ça c'est une
décision évidemment individuel c'était
aussi une façon de vivre et de ne pas se
laisser aller à la facilité et aux
bulles cognitive
la deuxième vidéo pour refonder la
politique il faut cesser de relativiser
cesser de penser que la science et
l'opinion c'est la même chose
retrouvez la hiérarchie des savoirs car
tout ne se vaut pas où c'est le mot
intelligence il taire les guérés c'est à
la fois mettre les connaissances
ensemble mais c'est aussi les choisir
les cueillir les guérés c'est cueillir
c'est à dire choisir en choisir
certaines et ne pas en choisir d'autres
et donc il est fondamental qu'on
retrouve le sens de la différence entre
celui qui sait et celui qui
objectivement ne sais pas entre la
science la vraie et l'opinion voir le
délire la troisième chose le troisième
conseil s'est mêlé athènes et sparte
vous savez on a souvent c'était deux
ennemis évidemment politique très très
fort mais athènes s'est évidemment
l'ouverture démocratique spar c'était
des gens qui avaient décidé depuis la
réforme de licques hurgues de devenir
d'abord et avant tout des combattants
moi je pense qu'il faut mêler les deux
on doit devenir des combattants du
savoir des athlètes de la connaissance
c'est la seule façon de redonner des
compétences qui a l'air de
l'intelligence artificielle vont
permettre à tout va permettre à tout le
monde de continuer à être employables et
de continuer à comprendre le monde
nos vieilles sociétés démocratiques
doivent devenir des athlètes de la
connaissance des spartiates de la
connaissance des combattants de la
connaissance et du savoir
c'est notre seule porte de sortie
positive
pour terminer je pars ferai une petite
remarque vous savez l'humanisme c'était
un projet politique aussi et à l'époque
à partir de thomasz mort n'a commencé
l'udc a forgé le mot on a commencé à
écrire pour la paix des utopies utopie
ça veut dire deux choses c'est à la fois
le mot qui nique le le lieu qui n'existe
pas ou tel poste c'est aussi et août au
poste le bon lieu le lieu qu'on a envie
de faire
et puis à partir de là beaucoup de gens
ont écrit des idées de société idéale
vous rendez pas compte aujourd'hui du
fait un peu bizarre que plus personne
n'est capable d'écrire ça on n'écrit
plus que des dystopies gattaca
terminator the island
blackmore évidemment on n'est plus
capable que d'écrire des utopies que
d'écrire des dystopies pardon revenons
capable d'utopie nous devons devenu
devons essayer de retrouver une capacité
à avoir une vision positive de la
modernité sans et techno béa ni
technophobes c'est simone de beauvoir
qui disait la fatalité ne triomphe que
si on croit en elle je crois que
aujourd'hui on est capable de se
reprendre en main encore ça va c'est
évidemment peut-être pas très optimiste
ce que j'ai dit ce soir mais savait ce
que disait g ce qui il faut avoir le
pessimisme de la raison et l'optimisme
de la volonté
merci
[Applaudissements]